i know many many congratulations how are
you feeling has it sunk in yet no not at
all i mean
i've barely had a moment to really sink
in and enjoy and embrace but um
yeah i can't wait to just celebrate
later with my team and um
yeah it means so much to me to be here
with the trophy it was always a dream to
win a grand slam so so to be here i
really just want to enjoy every single
second of this day have you managed to
speak to to your parents i know they're
back home in england have you managed to
have a conversation with them and what
have they been saying to you yeah i've
had a conversation um not on my phone i
haven't checked that yet but
uh they were they were extremely happy
and proud of me and you know they're my
toughest and biggest critics and
to have them you know say they're proud
and happy it just means absolutely
everything and yeah when i was out there
i definitely wanted to do it for them as
well as me because they've been through
a lot as well as me and you know i
wouldn't be here without them because
they played such a big role in my
upbringing but also my tennis
it's such a huge rise to prominence so
rapidly isn't it you know to be in a
situation where you've got the the
world's eyes on you
are you comfortable with that amount of
spotlight and that amount of exposure is
it going to take some getting used to
yeah i've got no idea what's going on
really outside of arthur ash outside of
our hotel because we've been in such a
big great zone and uh so focused and
just haven't taken any any anything else
into account because i knew exactly what
i had to do out there you know i'm going
out there just taking care of point
point business as usual i mean at the
end of the day like
you need to focus on the match and
that's exactly what i did so um yeah i'm
very very pleased with how i managed to
perform the last three weeks
was there a point just finally in this
remarkable run ten matches more than
anyone else has played was there a point
where you thought maybe this is possible
maybe my dream can come true this time
um
i mean it only really sunk in when i
after i won the semi-finals that i was
in the final of a grand slam like the
occasion there was no getting around you
know it's the first grand slam final but
it was the same for both of us so i we
threw absolutely everything we had at
each other and there was some great
tennis being played she's such a tough
opponent so i had to
play my absolute best and dig very deep
in the tough moments but yeah i came
through it in the end and extremely
happy
congratulations enjoy the celebrations
have you got anything planned
immediately for celebrating i've got no
idea what awaits me
brilliant thank you so much